su prioridad de subir de la violencia y
de la pobreza por ello para sus padres
no importa si tienen que realizar la
travesía solos la administración badén
informó que son más de 14.000 los
menores que han atravesado sin compañía
la frontera entre méxico y eeuu y ahora
permanecen bajo custodia de agencias
gubernamentales nueve mil quinientos
sesenta y dos de ellos están al cuidado
del departamento de salud y 4500 son
custodiados por la oficina de aduanas y
protección fronteriza
pese a las alarmantes cifras el gobierno
se niega a calificar la situación de
crítica una crisis ocurre cuando una
nación está dispuesta a arrancar a un
niño de nueve años de las manos de sus
padres y separar a esa familia para
disuadir la migración en el futuro
y eso para mí es una crisis humanitaria
ya lo que se ha comprometido el
presidente ya lo que me comprometo yo es
asegurar que tengamos un sistema
migratorio que funcione el migration
system de adwords el ejecutivo asegura
que contrario a lo ocurrido durante la
era trump no expulsa a niños que llegan
a eeuu sin compañía y las críticas
republicanas aumentan de estos sitios
donde están los menores son un resultado
directo de las imprudentes políticas de
fronteras abiertas del presidente bailén
que están provocando un aumento en los
cruces fronterizos y en actividad de los
cárteles la casa blanca ha enviado un
mensaje para disuadir a los migrantes
que buscan llegar irregularmente
vamos a seguir enfatizando que la
frontera no está abierta que la mayoría
de personas son devueltas y no entran a
eeuu y francamente el mensaje no es que
no vengan ahora es que no vengan de esta
forma nunca la manera de venir a eeuu es
mediante caminos legales
al tiempo ha señalado que mediante el
título 42 si se está realizando la
devolución a mexico de migrantes
irregulares tanto adultos solos como
grupos familiares para evitar la
propagación del cob y 19